hello everyone and welcome to another
game from round six of the 20/20
candidates tournament it's Alexandra
sugar versus Fabiano Caruana an exciting
game and again we get to see Bobby's
modern art angles variation of the real
Lopez at the highest level it's just
insane what far we can dig up at home
and before we check out the game we do
have a nice nice photo of the matchup
there you have it Fabian grief cook you
can see the difference in in body
positioning here you have Fabi who is
still playing his prepared line and
Grisha who is trying to work out the
madness on the board trying trying to
get closer to the pieces as you can see
so let's enjoy that for a second and
let's check out the game so like in his
game against MVL well a degree show by
the Greek opens would be four but Fabi
of course sorry about that
nose gree should most likely knows that
fab is going to go for the same line he
he played against them v l9 f3 with
Knight to c6 and Bishop to b5 the
reuleaux pieces on the board again a six
Bishop to a4 Knight to f6 and casts we
have b5 by Fabi Bishop to b3 and Bishop
to c5 so the modern art angles and we we
mentioned it's quite quite an exciting
opening as its it's getting repeated
quite a lot especially by Fabi a4 we
have rook to b8 everything the same as
in game boxing martial aggresses Fabiano
karana from the candidates c 3 d 6 and
now d4 the Shabak to b6 and now this a5
move which we explained why it's
off-limits to capture it in that video
maxime versus Fabi if you haven't seen
it do check it out so there should be
back the a7 and now h3 we have castles
so still following the game against
Maxime Bishop to e3 and now in the game
against Maxine father went each
character son before but now we have
this interesting in between rook to e8
which is extremely rare it's been played
only once before but it actually comes
with a threat and now it's a bit
different because this after this threat
of capturing you you also have the
threat of just picking up the e4 pawn as
now it
we'll be attacked twice so what can you
do here here Grishka
played a very original move here he's
played Knight to g5 which comes with a
double attack on the f7 square Fabi
repeated rook to faith and the group
went back Knight to f3 here Fabi
repeated rook to e8 and here Grisha
again repeated Knight to g5 and it was
in this position that they agreed to a
draw that of course is a joke of course
they did not agree to a draw here after
this rook to e8 repetition by Fabi and
Grisha started thinking and he really
started thinking he thought for some 41
minutes if I'm not mistaken which is a
lot but it's not a lot for Greece of
time in Greece of time that's moderate
as he he tends the thing even more for a
single move but here also we have a very
nice that's not that a nice photo of the
two of them you can see Greece shook
that's about the same position as this
one staring at his clock as the time
keeps running out and here he goes for
rook to e1 which is a temporary pawn
sacrifice but offers a lot of play so
Fabi immediately played eke a person
before without much consideration see
captors and e4 in the knight characters
on e4 grabbing that pawn and now d5 with
a double attack against the knight and
also the bishop on age 7 so here Bishop
captures a nice serene by Fabi rook
captures on e3 and now Knights the a7
and here Grisha goes for Queen d4 with a
double attack on the knight and also
with an attack on the night here and
here of course you're expecting Knight
to c5 just get both nights out of harm's
way but here Fabi immediately plays
Bishop to a5 saying I'm still in a
prepared line and you you have a good
luck with this so what's what's the idea
here obviously there's the offering of a
knight here we read you the position
from the thumbnail but can the knight be
captured or not well that's that's a
that's a very difficult question to
answer in theory yes
but it will be very hard to play it over
the board for example after Queen
characters here Fabi has nice the c5
plan now the threat is rook to b7 to
trap the Queen here so
have to go for characters captures the
eliminated the c-7 pawn and now Knight
captures and b3 attacking the rook and
also if the rook moves the knight is
under attack so rook has to attack night
and now Knight back the c5 leaving the
night and b1 under attack but now Queen
captures on d6 saying that okay if you
capture this I'm gonna capture this guy
over here and now b4 by half a be
pushing back the rook and after the rook
moves you have to block the Queen's
influence on the e-file Queen to f8 now
offering a queen trade captures captures
and now as the night is still under
attack Knight bTW - and now the game
continues probably rock the 8th and
something we're fob you would be down
upon but he would have a bishop against
a knight in a in a position that he's
much more familiar with that he analyzed
at home deeply and of course a good
issue already very long time doesn't
doesn't want to play this this end game
so that's that's basically what happens
if you capture and then continue with
perfect play so here Gary shook instead
went Knight B to d2 he ignores the
knight now threatens to just a win win
the piece here and now Knight back to c5
by Fabi we have group capture Sonny a
true Queen captures an e 8 and now rook
to e1 winning the e-file for the rook
Queen to f8 by Fabi and now Bishop back
to d1 getting the bishop out of harm's
way and now b4 by Fabi wanting to go all
the way with b3 we have the ship to e2
now shifting the bishop to a more useful
diagonal and preparing to bring it all
the way to f1 we have Queen to d8 now
maybe with some ideas that for example
if c6 is played then maybe you can snap
off the a 5 point so Bishop the f1 back
and now comes h6 creating a breathing
room for the King also an Isis escape
square for the Bishop if needed
rook to e3 now controlling the the d3
square before you couldn't really worry
about something like this as the knight
would still hang so here first b3 by
Fabi pushing the pawn even further and
now comes Queen to f4
attacking the bishop here Bishop the
back to d7 and now comes Knight to d4
and now the night the night has access
to f5 to c6 if needed the b5 so a very
useful square for the night we have
worked a B for Bobby now pins the night
as the queen is on f4 and now rooked g3
a very nice rock lift by by Grisha and
now maybe even Queen captures and h6 is
an idea and here Fabi goes for Queen to
e7
so what's Queen to e7 why is Queen
captures and h6 or off limits and is it
off limits so let's say we capture Queen
captures an 86 why wouldn't we do you
see what Fabi had in mind here even
pause the video and and try to figure it
out
while I haven't I sip of my water so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations
and being a magnificent defender and for
those of you who just won't enjoy the
show it doesn't work because of Queen e5
and now you defend mate the night still
hangs and you have to do something about
it and the point is if you move the
night or if you defend the night this
way it doesn't really matter whichever
move you make Queen captures in g3
that's the point
and now after capture so you just
capture the Queen and h6 because there's
no longer the pin along the G file and
at the end of the line you are up a
whole rook so very sneaky move by Fabi
Queen to e7
and now Grisha goes after the b3 pawn
Bishop to c4 adds yet another attacker
to the b3 pawn Bobby goes Knights the b5
and now Knight a night for characters on
b3 we have Knight captures and b3 rook
captures on b3 now and Queen t1 with
chick King goes to H 2 and now rook
captures on v3 we have nightcap Tristan
b3 and now Queen to b4
putting more restraint on angry chokes
pieces now of course you cannot move the
bishop because the Queen hands so you
have to do something about it so here
Luke tries for Queen to b4 probably an
idea that if c6 you can maybe maybe
capture here but Bobby says that that
will not work here Fabi instead goes c5
he just advances the pawn gets rid of
his a weak pawn on c7 and now says if
you character
Bishop to e6 will be just ugly for you
so you cannot in fact capture here on
Poisson so after c5 we have Queen to d3
now by Gary shook and we have g6 now so
you don't have to worry about any any
threats along this diagonal for example
if you want to go King f8 improve the
position of the King and so on so after
Queen d3 we have g6 and now G for not
allowing Bishop to a5 to kick away the
Queen King to g7 and now King g2 and
here we have Knight the c7 by Fabi hear
the engine slightly prefers bishop here
the the point is after Queen to c7 you
just exchange Queens with Quintus III
probably Bishop to c8 is preferred as it
it weights it it doesn't give me sugar
the opportunity to immediately trade off
Queen so maybe first go after the pawn
and then go Knight to c7 to create a
double attack against the pawn so maybe
this is a why it's slightly preferred
but ok Knight to c7 you also need to
keep an eye on the pawn here so of
course if Bishop captures you just
capture and after Queen captures you
capture on b3 so it's not a problem so
here just queen c3 check by Grisha we
have Queen captures B captures and now F
5 by Fabi and okay Knight back the d2 by
Gary shook saying that if you go for
characters here you lose control of the
e4 squared that's why nice the d2 is
very strong for example if characters
captors and characters just 94 will pick
up this pawn and there's not much you
can do here if you defend it in of
course in the night no longer defend e
it defends the a6 pawn so King to f6
Fabi starts bringing the King into the
game now King g3 Grisha does the same
and Bishop to b5 hoping to fix his pawn
structure here but Bishop to b3 avoiding
the trade and now Bishop to e2 taking
away squares from the White King and
here comes G captures on f5 with G cap
present f5 King captures an f5 seems
like a more reasonable thing to do not
mess up your pawn structure but then
after f4 you don't really have a way to
play this with your King these squares
are all taken so the King cannot
approach anything and
if you want you can always maybe even
kick away the king it's even quite
dangerous to keep your king there if he
didn't have the df6 square it would be
checkmate for example he tonight was
here then Bishop c2 would eat the
checkmate for example so have to be
careful so G captures on f5 instead and
now still f4 as all these squares are
now covered the the black King cannot
really use any means to approach the
pawns and now Knight the b5 going after
the c3 pawn agree shook attacks at c4 we
have Knight to c3 and now Bishop back to
C to just keeping an eye on the e4
square we have brush-up to d1 offering a
trade and Bishop to d3 angry sugar
declines and now Knights to a to trying
to trying to get hold of some other
pawns maybe with ideas like night here
maybe here if the knight moves but still
waiting for whites to make a move with
King to f2 and now Knight the B for
going after the bishop King the e3 and
now Bishop the c2 again with a double
attack here Bishop to e2 declining the
trade and Knight back to eat Knight back
to a2 we have Knights to f1 by Griff
shook and now Knight the c1 here we have
King to be two with a double attack and
here we just have a trade capture skin
captures of course not the bishop as DF
for pawn would hang so King captures
here and after the shop to a four it was
now in this position that they actually
agreed to a draw on move 54 so here it's
it's a draw because there's not much you
can do here all of the squares are taken
so you can't really advance your King
through any squares and it's just just a
very block position that the black also
here controls the squares so the white
king cannot approach and well anything
could happen either of them could maybe
blunder or something but of course both
of them know that this is a draw and
that there is no point in playing it out
so they agreed to a draw and really
really a nice game
so again if I be in the same variation
almost in the same line shows what kind
of poison he can dig up and it's
angry shift the either take a draw in
that position that we mentioned here
after Luke t8 do you just repeat an IG
five here and go back rukia up here or
do you go for a 41 minute thing in go
rookie one like the brave Alexander
group did and then this whole game
happens where he suffers for for a long
time but in the end you know he
eventually finds out the truth sure yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
we're going to show at least one more
game from round six and then we're gonna
discuss the standings so I'm not gonna
show any now just so I don't spoil it
for some of you who are maybe not
following the results as vividly I would
like to thank Harry Willis a gladkov
chunk of Randall Ingersoll David Dunn
and Daniel a bibbing for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos you're thinking for
watching and I will see you soon of
course continuing the coverage of the
candidates tournament thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day
[Music]